et notez que nous sommes aujourd'hui le
11 janvier 2002 il y a deux ans jour
pour jour la chine annoncé le premier
mort d'une pneumonie atypique mort cause
en réalité donc par ce virus qui a
modifié notre quotidien à tous depuis
deux ans le coït 19 afin d'éviter d'être
contaminé par son fils positif au co
vide cette enseignante texane l'a
enfermée dans le coffre de sa voiture
pour aller le faire tester sur le
parking d'un stade à houston en
découvrant la situation le personnel
soignant a exigé que l'adolescent
s'assied à l'arrière du véhicule une
fois le test effectué sahara a été
interpellé par la police puis relâché le
lendemain contre une caution de 1500 $
le canada a décidé d'autoriser la vente
d'alcool et de cassis bien uniquement
aux personnes vaccinées selon les
estimations de notre propre institut de
sondage chine telle mesure était
appliquée en france aujourd'hui le taux
de français vaccinés atteindrait les
245% obama mec ne croyez pas qu'il ya 50
millions de personnes qui sont en rien
pour moi effectif regarde moi je vous
dis doivent bien entre eux on à dire 40
% de faux pas ne faut pas je peux vous
en parler parce que j'ai une de mes
amies donc natacha qui travaillent avec
moi et qui a vraiment enquêter et elle
est tombée sur des chiffres
gouvernementaux officiel disons
qu'aujourd'hui et les 36 % 36 pts c902
personnes qui en mai au canada cette
mesure at-elle porté ses fruits après
l'action voici la réaction le ministre
dubé communiquer son enthousiasme au
sujet des prises de rendez vous pour la
première dose qui sont passés de 1500
par jour à plus de 6 milliards
sur le président c'est ce qui vous reste
à faire qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'on a des
idées en démocratie eh ben on fonde un
parti alors ça paraît un peu ringard un
parti politique une synthèse simple et
donc j'ai fondé un parti qui s'appelle
simple re sillonner la france pour
justement récolter des témoignages de
complexité pour valider quelque part
cette intuition et aujourd'hui j'ai
décidé d'aller jusqu'au bout de cette
démarche et donc de me présenter à
l'élection présidentielle puisque c'est
le moment où peuvent émerger des forces
politiques nouvelles en france il avait
fait un tour de france il ya quelques
temps ce avec son mouvement qui simple
on l'a vu affiché derrière c'était pour
la chaleur et pour la des conflits
plaignent des complexification des
normes et juste avant il avait fait ou
un tour notamment d'europe puisqu'il
avait décidé d'aller sur les traces de
montaigne avec son cheval honnêtement
destine à da c'était il y à peu près st
en 2020 entre les deux confinement
pourquoi monteyne car mon vol a survécu
car montaigne en 1580 et sa lutte le
s'est il amusé la galerie le doivent
besoin très bien il avait voulu
rejoindre mon salon wii rejoindre rome
et depuis bordeaux s'est prise là et et
le cheval ne s'en est pas remis le bol
des 204 derrière faut démontrer pour le
panama jamais ça vous dit fouad à métaux
marcel rossé le symbole crédit du cheval
mais c'est intéressant pioche
ça va être très compliqué mais c'est pas
maintenant qu'il faut flanché au fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok ça nous a pas échappé en corée du sud
la présidentielle c'est très bientôt le
9 mars prochain et m'échapper du tout
les nerfs je sais bien c'est pour ça que
je vous signale que lee et james young
et candidat du parti démocrate favori
des sondages est bien à une proposition
qui fait le buzz sa dernière idée est au
coeur de la campagne comme nous le
raconte courrier international il
propose la prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale des soins contre la
calvitie autrement dit des implants
gratuits pour tous les coréens
orange c'est par orange c'était orange
avec une mèche ouverte pour faire une
orange ont détruit mais voilà c'était
orange le fruit est derrière j'avais les
cheveux rasés en forme de quartier pour
faire des quartiers
d'orange ça va pas la tête
la calvitie est une maladie dit-il ceux
qui n'en sont pas atteints ne peuvent
pas comprendre le stress la souffrance
que nous vivons et les regards que nous
endurons j'appelle les 10 millions de
chauves à se mobiliser derrière moi dix
candidats et ça marche sa proposition a
d'abord été moquée mais la presse note
que parmi les quarante mesures qu'il a
proposées basse est de loin celle qui a
le plus de succès vous vous ressemblez
rien entre deux tournages c'est ce que
vous dites daniel comment vous dire moi
je ressemble à rien entre deux tournages
je reste beau
[Rires]
avec cette espèce de flamme cette beauté
intérieure il y a dix ans avec franck on
s'est dit oui pour la première fois
j'étais enceinte de petits paulo dix ans
après je suis encore et je suis
suffisamment bête et stupide pour faire
deux fois la même erreur donc j'ai
redemandé la main de mélanie nature à
devenir ma femme
oui j'avais une demande particulière à
de faire jaser
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie
ils ont ce même pas ne pense même pas
ça l'a
aimée par ange les ouailles s'éclate
d'ailleurs ils ont divorcé pour mieux
profiter de leur jeunesse donc à 70 ans
il s'éclate mon père il fait la
trottinette électrique ma mère elle sort
tous les soirs c'est elle qui me donne
des plans pour sortir big wave annonce
barbazan ça c'est elle qui sait mais oui
j'ai hâte d'adieu non mais c'est pour
bientôt isabelle donc toi t'as 21 en or
je vais sur mes 23 à 24 enfants
tous et sa virginie elle a l'air très
gentil mais ça pourrait être ma mère
c'est pas trop mon truc c'est des photos
ok mais je garde surtout les yeux grands
ouverts sur mes enfants elle voulait n'a
pas perdu les nerfs fo les roulades l
eau non non non non non non non non non
non je fous les roulades mais non c'est
pas les nôtres c'est vrai c'est pas les
nôtres
voulez vous parler des victoires de la
musique qui seront de retour pour une
37e édition la cérémonie sur douloureux
roulera à la scène musicale à boulogne
billancourt à quelques pas d'ici alors
j'adore les deux présentateurs laury
thilleman olivier minne mais
malheureusement je vais être obligé de
boycotter cette soirée est une vraie me
son nom
c'est de l'amener à rim a à g ou dire
pourquoi on va dire la vérité absent de
la liste le plus gros vendeur de disques
grand corps malade absent des deux soirs
de la mine s'il n'y a pas de la
magouille dans ses lectures d'amis que
je demande à tout le monde de boycotter
cette dream de son nom
[Musique]
aux etats unis un petit robot humanoïde
ce petit robot qui s'appelle john
d'euros bottes vont s'élancer dans le
stand-up depuis quelques années donc
devant du public est là raconte des
blagues pour l'instant écrite par un
humain et voilà ce qui me dit par
exemple eh oui
pourquoi